ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dylan shyam sunburned again and I have
aloe vera on my face now so I look shiny
and red and you can ridicule that if
you'd like but I got that sunburn in a
least a seven million dollar home who's
a stunning estate and many of you uh
let's just put it this way it wasn't
your average lake house okay I know you
out there well it's just it's the same
Beach it ain't it truly ain't
LAPD now testing wants to test everyone
for coronavirus that they arrest so if
you cannot get a corona virus test in
Los Angeles commit a crime commit a
crime and you'll be taken care of
no problem we've got our magic spoon for
our 200th episode we'll be treating
ourselves to some magic spoon cereal
with zero grams of sugar three net carbs
11 grams of protein and of course some
almond milk you know it's we're not
gonna talk about them because you don't
[ __ ] give us anything [ __ ] them
that's what it is out here um my dad
we're gonna get into this later on in
the episode but my father sent me a I
don't know what you would call it it's
just the it's the rules there's one
restaurant in Long Island I don't know
if he's been there I'm sure he like said
he you know I'm sure he's been there and
likes it but he sent me a you know it's
on their website the rules of how
they're gonna reopen their restaurant
and it's kind of crazy all of the things
that they're going to have to do just to
get any type of crowd back in the
restaurant and I don't know why it's not
coming up there comes up on my phone
I'll get my dad saying it comes up
immediately on the phone I might just
not be coming up there
no one's gonna go out to eat this is
what we're really gonna would
it's coming down to when you when we go
through all the rules that I mean did no
one I love going out to eat it's no one
loves it that much that you're gonna sit
there and then people are gonna come out
and beekeeper outfits and then hand you
a butter and then there's gonna be a
ball of hand sanitizer and there's not
gonna be any tablecloth so they're gonna
be wiping down the table hey it's gonna
be a car wash who the hell wants to eat
in a [ __ ] car wash where everything
what are you smiling about I'm reading
the rules the rules are in saya read
some of the rules these are some of the
rules for this Italian restaurant in
Long Island to just to just get back to
serving any kind of food inside all
right
reopening guidelines all employees will
wear gloves and mask during service
until recommended by the CDC or in New
York State fun so let's just picture
that you're at a table you're at a table
in the restaurant in Long Island by the
way half of these people aren't
following the rules they're gonna take
the match they'll be like you know this
is [ __ ] the whole thing is fake but
Obama what you know Obama created this
to make a [ __ ] us wear masks yeah so
I gotta [ __ ] wear this [ __ ]
hand sanitizer will be readily available
to guests
and I'm sure Long Island they'll do it
in a very classy way I'm sure there's
gonna be very classy way to get hand
sanitizer to the guests like fountains
of it that are you know lit on fire
there's gonna be like hand sanitizer ice
luge's
in steak houses in Long Island people
just stick in their dirty myths in a
[ __ ] big bowl of hand sanitizer I'm
sure that I'm sure that's smart masks
and gloves will be provided by the
restaurant please alert management if
there is none great so not only are the
waitstaff in masks and gloves you will
get masks and gloves from the management
so that you can put it on so you can
have gloves and a mask on
while you're eating so that you just
take the mess down and eat and then put
the mask back up I guess I guess I guess
I guess I don't know I don't know how
well thought thought-out this is all
tables are disinfected before and after
seedings in service hours good so they
cut so they disinfect it right in front
of you like a wool like you know like
you like sitting at Wendy's where they
come up with the spray bottle and then
they wipe it down there's nothing better
than paying $75 for a steak and getting
the table sprayed down in front of you
by a guy in a mask kitchen will be
sanitized I mean that makes sense well
it won't be but that's anything out of
sight well nothing's happening
especially in Long Island
we're not doing any of this [ __ ] [ __ ] in
the kitchen keep the food coming keep it
hot keep it comin all surfaces are wipes
down disinfected routinely following
cleaning schedule great so just every
surface you see he's gonna get get a
dirty rag going across it multiple times
a night there's nothing better than
going out for a romantic meal and just
watching people clean God nothing better
than the smell of hand sanitizer and
disinfected which were all [ __ ]
desensitized to now by the way just the
smell of gente oh honey how are you
don't you enjoy that what's that aroma
oh it it's ammonia do you like it it's
the chemical that's gonna kill us and in
several years worse than the corona
virus well it's this is nine pages long
it's not pet keep going for a little bit
I just want to know a few more of the
things all sanitation is scheduled and
recorded okay health guest health guests
will be asked for contact info for
notification this is what it gets good
keep going with this this is some of my
favorite read this again guests will be
asked for contact info for notifications
of contagion and pledge that they have
not felt any symptoms of Kovan 19 a
pledge and we all know in Long Island
it's a truthful group of people so they
will show they're also gonna be asked
about their family history
before they get in the restaurant by the
way that's gonna cheer everybody up so I
hate Vinny we hate to do this but you
know anybody too tired of Co yeah my
mother [ __ ] died in a [ __ ] nursing
home I'm trying to [ __ ] forget that
Cuomo let her [ __ ] burning attic she
lit it on fire let the [ __ ] burn this
[ __ ] let it burn he gives
himself a raise I was trying to forget
about that but coming out here to LA
abbondanza and trying to have [ __ ]
lasagna and now I gotta talk about it
okay this one I don't understand
Matilda's law will be enforced as long
as it remains in effect
okay Matilda's law a lot of people don't
know what Matilda's law is on Long
Island Matilda's law is if if a woman is
enough of a [ __ ] she doesn't have to
follow any of these rules some Matilda's
law is named after a woman named Matilda
ah
Fabrice ecoan and she was in Italian Jew
and she was the most annoying person
it's ever lived and no matter what the
law is she's such a [ __ ] and she's so
loud that they just let her she's like
I'm not putting on no [ __ ] mask I
don't give a [ __ ] I don't know
so that's Matilda's law they don't I
don't know what Matilda's lawyers okay
so this one I don't know if this holds
up customers over 70 are not allowed to
dine within our walls or not I love that
customers over 70 which is everyone on
Long Island the youngest person in Long
Island is in their mid 60's everyone
over 70 is not allowed to dine within
our walls how nice is that
seven year-olds can't go to dinner
anymore Wow seventies not that old
either
no it's not 70 years old you can't go to
dinner now within our walls you can eat
in the parking lot you can eat in the
lot employees will take and record
contactless temperature checks as well
as take health pledge daily the health
pledge yeah I'm sure no one will lie
about that and by the way what if you
have a symptom of Kovan you don't have
Kovan right doesn't this sound inse--
like it it seems like it's a lot and by
the way if it this is that transmissible
does any is this [ __ ] even help well
max c'mon parties are for maximum
parties of four I like that I do like
that someone's got to go this is gonna
be a renegotiation of all the risks we
take in our life people are gonna be
like how much do we like these people
how much do we want to have dinner with
them how much does this couple need to
be here do we really like that movie do
we really like that comedian do we
really and I'm here to tell you what
industries are gonna go and what are
gonna stay I'm gonna tell you that okay
because I have a Facebook that's my
qualifications I'm a citizen and I'll
tell you any industry that involves me
he's gonna stay for a little while it's
gonna stay around and I'm not and that
is a conflict of interest but it's the
truth
college is done you [ __ ] at a paid 40
grand a year to learn where and when you
start vomiting what beers too many what
your tolerance is and sitting around
listening to professors babble who have
no other marketable skills except
talking who are those people can you
imagine that some people these
professors
they do nothing but talk for hours and
it's the only money they make is talking
it's ridiculous and it'll be stopped I
won't allow it a post covert world will
not allow these bloviating
professors they say anything and the and
and that's all they do is just sit or
stand and talk and I am disgusted with
that archetype of person so they're
gonna have to get real [ __ ] jobs and
figure it out college is done I am sorry
it needs to be remodeled and remade
into something that prepares people for
actual life it should prepare you for
actually doing something you can't spend
years and years just having weird
threesomes and protesting things you
barely understand and you know sitting
in the library doing adderall it's time
to come into the world come to the
market now see what skills you have we
got to start reforming college and we
will a lot of colleges struggling
colleges are not gonna make it to this
this is a big scam try to ensure guests
stay separate while waiting to be seated
cracked so if one tip party four comes
in and another party four comes in and
they might want to talk to each other
because they live in the same
neighborhood or know each other they
can't do that somebody's gonna have to
come up to them and go Liz will you two
shut the [ __ ] up and you here's what's
hilarious about this do you know how in
artfully this is gonna be done on Long
Island
do you have any idea how you know you're
not supposed to [ __ ] talk cut the
[ __ ] talk it out just shut the [ __ ]
up for five minutes we're getting your
tables on a god we don't want to get
shut down by the government I mean do
you know how poorly this will all be
executed
I know they don't make it a day with all
of these regulations there's no way this
even happens in Long Island there's no
way there's a whole section about mental
health oh you're the whole section about
mental health as you say it is an island
where I would say on Long Island 30
percent of people are mentally ill
mentally unwell 30 percent of them are
mentally unwell the whole section about
mental health we've all heard it if you
can't take the heat then best stay out
of the kitchen but all too often in the
restaurant industry the heat burns on
longer than your shed this mandatory
pause the service has allowed us to
consider what's already a global issue
and how service mental well-being yeah
mental well-being great the new world
folks
you want a bowl of spaghetti get ready
for an episode of American Ninja Warrior
to get to your table get ready for
hurdles and foam pants and sanitizer and
you know get ready for it it's insane
but I don't know I just don't know who's
I love going out to dinner it's one of
the things I specialize in I'm very good
at it some people aren't good at it
people we all know the people that are
good at it they don't know what they're
doing they say stupid things when they
sit down at a table they don't you know
you know they peruse the menu too long
they don't get it
they order the wrong thing take them to
a steak house he order breasts of
chicken we know who these people are
they're just not they're not good at
going out to dinner they haven't put the
time in like I have they've they put the
time in like having a relationship or
earning money starting a family okay
sure have all of that but you get them
out and you go oh yeah you're not fun
they don't have a good story they don't
have a quick anecdote they don't
understand that like they got to wrap it
up before the waitress gets there you
know that there's a rhythm to a dinner
there's a rhythm to a dinner that works
well and it's just it's gonna be
completely destroyed completely
destroyed with a lot of these guidelines
that are coming in I mean it's just it's
just a death knell to the restaurant
business as we know it it's crazy and I
and this is a business that I'm a I've
always wanted to own a restaurant if I
didn't do this for a living if I wasn't
a comedian I might be in that business I
don't know um I probably wouldn't I'd
probably do in some real estate scam in
southern Florida with the elderly but I
would still always enjoy restaurants and
it's sad I can't imagine them unless we
have a few months without a case and
people are just like [ __ ] who cares
unless there's a national [ __ ] who
cares unless there's some type of
vaccine unless there's an antiviral drug
that works all of these things seem less
likely you know the vaccine the viral
drug all these things seem
likely I'm not anti vaccine I just want
to know what the [ __ ] going on I just
want to be I just want to hand the world
over to Jeff Bezos and Bill Gates and
all of these trillionaires billionaires
soon-to-be trillionaire as let them do
whatever they want you see this new
thing on Facebook all these boomers are
sharing it and they're like how did Bill
Gates who's the best man that ever lived
who save more lives he saves lives of
the Congo he saved lives for polio how
did Bill Gates be turned into some
villain by this I love Bill Gates I
don't care that he wants to shoot a
missile full of dust at the Sun and
block out the Sun who cares it's I hate
the Sun my sis I thought I'd a melanoma
last week it turned out it wasn't it was
just a pile of dirt that collected on my
body and I didn't watch it but I thought
it was cancer I hate the thought I don't
care that Bill Gates
what's the tunnel to the center of the
earths and bring back the dinosaurs he's
a good boy he's the local point to done
good he's just all he does is try to
help people every day after the
government monopolized date they busted
him on all these Monopoly things he went
into philanthropy and decide he didn't
want to he wants to give his money away
to his charity organizations to give to
you know schools that where his son goes
but and and you know dodge taxes all
over the world by buy a bike you know by
playing [ __ ] come here with the
needle and [ __ ] whatever third-world
country won't kick him out I like Bill
and I don't want to hear anything
negative said about him
not at all it doesn't matter that he
wants to send nuclear weapons to Mars
and blow it out
just for fun he understands global
warming comes from the Sun get rid of
the [ __ ] Sun get that article I get
Bill Gates wants to shoot dust it to Sun
by the way this is what happens when you
let people get billions of trillions of
dollars and then nobodies you know
that's all he just wants to shoot some
dust at the Sun here we go
what could go wrong could dimming the
Sun save the earth
Bill Gates wants to spray millions of
tons of dust into the stratosphere to
stop global warming but critics fear it
could trigger calamity [ __ ] these
critics
how dare who are these critics
astronomers scientists who are these
have they not heard of Windows who are
these critics stopping him from shooting
dust into the [ __ ] into the
atmosphere who is saying it's not a good
idea to block out the Sun why not let
him experiment it's fun why are all
these conspiracy theorists what's their
problem he doesn't want the Sun anymore
he wants to dim the Sun this is not a
crackpot plan of a garden shed inventor
the project is being funded by
billionaire and Microsoft founder Bill
Gates and pioneer by scientists at
Harvard Epstein University keep going
down here come go out for a minute go
out from it in theory the airborne toss
would create a gigantic Sun Shade
reflecting some of the sun's rays and
heat back into space dimming those that
get through so protecting Earth from the
worsening ravages of climate warming
keep going down here the initial three
million-dollar test known as the
stratospheric controlled Petra bation
experiment would use a high-altitude
scientific balloon to raise around two
kilograms of calcium carbonate dust the
size of a bag of flour into the
atmosphere twelve miles above the desert
of New Mexico
this would seed a tube shaped area of
the sky about half a mile long a hundred
yards in diameter for the ensuing 24
hours a balloon would be steered by
propellers back through the artificial
cloud its onboard sensors monitoring
this dust Sun reflecting abilities and
its effect on the thin surrounding air
okay however scope acts on is on hold
this is what they're calling it I guess
Kopacz is on hold amid fears it could
trigger a disastrous series of chain
reactions creating climate havoc in the
form of serious droughts and hurricanes
and bring death to millions of people
around the world I don't want a bad word
about bail how did a man who just wants
to cure disease and get rid of the Sun
get a bad rap
on Facebook all these Yahoo's are making
fun of William I love Bill so what he
wants Americans to live underground so
that the ravages of global warming don't
stop them he wants to create a slave of
a slave race of Lycans who has white
skin because they're all albinos they
could live underground it's nice under
grams you ever been underground it's
lovely stop it stop telling bill what to
do he's got billions of dollars let him
do what he wants that's where they go
let him do what they want hey let him do
they want half Jeff Bezos wants to
automate and just destroy grocery stores
and everybody just could have drone if
Apple's dropped off just let him do it
let him do it doesn't matter that's a
millions of people are gonna lose their
jobs who cares doesn't matter let them
let it if they can design a robot let
him do it doesn't matter doesn't matter
doesn't really matter we'll just let
them do whatever they want we don't want
to debate the pace of which people's
jobs are going to evaporate and be taken
over by AI let him do it's get it one of
the Harvard teams directors Lizzie burns
admits our idea is terrifying but so is
climate change
so is climate change so I want to hear
Bill I don't want to hear bad word about
Bill I can't believe you ninnies would
say anything so he knows he's up to no
good by the way if you ever see his
Facebook gates by the way he knows kind
of up to no good yes he wants to save
people's lives kind of but let's get
real here there's some other things
percolating and that old dome of his
there's a lot of good with the bad I'm
sure Jeffrey Epstein was nice to
waitresses maybe I don't know what if we
found that I've seen was a big tipper
and he never complained and he never
sent his food back you know I see a
Coulter note and Hitler didn't smoke
like everybody's got a thing that's nice
about them and I'm it's nice that Bill
Gates wants to cure infectious diseases
and then somehow that will also bring
the population of the planet down there
he wants to do that I get it there's too
many people I'm in LA there's too much
traffic I get it I'm with him but if you
look in his eyes and his doll
he's got some other things going on let
me tell you [ __ ] thank God I don't
have a billion dollars thank God I don't
have a billion dollars I'd be [ __ ] I
mean I wish I were him right now I would
be [ __ ] I would be doing some much
wildest [ __ ] than he is you just got to
watch him you got to watch Bezos you got
to watch these people we know that the
government is an app the government and
private industry have gotten in bed
together and they've created what were
people like Chris Hedges have called the
corporate state which means it has all
the power of the state and all the and
and and the endless financial resources
and also all the like you know supposed
credibility of the private sector where
we bring in these geniuses incredibly
intelligent we all know like Bill Gates
is not a dumb guy Bezos and all these
guys are incredibly intelligent people
so we bring them in and then because we
all know people work the government kind
of dunces we all think the government's
you know up until recently when
everybody showed with Obama and Trump
and everyone's like these are gods Obama
obviously smart guy and Trump is
intelligent in his own way but the
reality is we know these geniuses exist
for the most part outside of the
government they exist making billions of
traffic wants to work for the government
when you got heads like these guys have
they want to truly revolutionize the
world great but when they team up with
the government they're just this
unstoppable force nothing can stop them
truly nothing don't like what you're
right they delete it you don't exist
your own person doesn't matter you're
getting this health policy whether you
like it or not these are the required
things you don't like surveillance will
[ __ ] you you don't like your email read
let's get read FBI can go into your
search history now it doesn't matter FBI
go right in your search history what do
you search you for you search them for
something they don't like okay the FBI's
like we are we are looking at all of the
searches and we don't mind any we will
be we don't mind anyone searching for
child porn as long as they make a
certain amount of money and they're
searching through our approved partners
but we dude we don't really love if
if you're on some anti-government forum
we don't love that don't propagate any
conspiracy theories don't say anything
mean about Bill's plan to block the Sun
out keep your mouth shut about that just
put a bag over your head and go to your
local Italian restaurant and get wiped
down with hand sanitizer before you eat
and let bill and the boys do their work
let bill and the boys do their work
stay awake here it's a little crazy out
there
these [ __ ] on Facebook what are you
getting checks of bill Malloy relax
real I know the other side's nuts they
think everybody in LA is a [ __ ]
trillionaire it's [ __ ] kids and you
know I get how crazy those [ __ ]
people are too and I think Bill Gates is
the Antichrist and everything goes back
to Jesus everything goes back to
Revelations and Jesus and I get it I get
it and they think Donald Trump is you
know got a little hat with a light and
he's going through the tunnels under
Central Park trying to free the kids we
get it we know that that's not the
answer either okay we we understand most
people in this business live in a car by
the way they're not in they're not in
big mansions [ __ ] kids they're trying
to hoard themselves out they have their
[ __ ] on the street trying to get any
money saying come on me do whatever you
want just buy me dinner
so let's this idea that everybody huh
doesn't even exist anymore these parties
that ever talking about the Hollywood I
don't even know I don't even know anyone
who knows anyone who has them it doesn't
even exist it's me and Whitney Cummings
eating magic spoon in her backyard
trying to wait for a bobcat to come
she's like a bobcat was here three days
ago I hope we see the Bobcat today
that's the elite parties that just
[ __ ] everybody thinks is going on
here I'm sure there are better pine oh
that there's better parties whatever you
know you know I get it but these lurid
ideas of what's going on in his town but
but you know listen you can't swing so
far the other pendulum where you're like
well I just I just I just sit in my
house and I wait for lizzo to tell me
what to do
I just went
let out a tweet the road stay home stay
home forever and bake Brad share it
inspirational story
there's people that've never made more
money in their life than this quarantine
I know people who've never made more
money in the life right now that are
sitting around every every package that
gets to talked about getting passed I
know guys that are chomping at the bit
chomping it's a bit like a cat looking
at a fish ball every time Nancy Pelosi
talks about another a little below
package I'm not saying that there's not
a lot of people hurting out there there
is I just happen to know dirtbags to
take advantage of the system I don't
happen to know a lot of people that are
like genuinely salt-of-the-earth people
I've never met any of these
salt-of-the-earth people that are out
there I want to I see them I know
they're there
I just don't attract him into my orbit I
attract thieves goons and liars so
they're riding this out like they rode
hurricane sandy out Long Island
hurricane sandy was the best thing that
happened to Long Island because it gave
all of my friends a decade excuse for
the failure that was inevitable anyway I
had one friend like eff Erica charities
the Dutch Wall don't live on the water
it's that's risky and it's like no you
don't live on the water because you
failed out of Nassau Community College
and you have a you have a criminal
record that's part of the reason yeah
hurricane sandy people right after
everybody's house got destroyed
everybody was like well here's my uh you
know I was working as a medical biller
before Hurricane sandy everything was
coming together I was going to get
married with Vincent and then the
hurricane happens and our entire lives
got turned upside down
thank you news 12 for letting us say our
grievances
Obama did this cuz he is black we know
that he did it with his black which
powers that he adds from his country he
did this the long island because we
voted for that other guy
McCain meant whoever the white one
anyway
hurricane sandy ruined our lives yes I
was technically fired from my job two
weeks before the hurricane for showing
up drunk coronavirus could be the new
hurricane sandy everybody's gonna be
everybody's just gonna be just it's just
gonna be one word you know they're gonna
base what he'd been up to and some
people just gonna go oh come on Ridge
well it mm-hmm you need a wallet you can
sanitize that's the game right now so if
you have a Ridge wallet it is a [ __ ]
beautiful wat let me tell you about this
wallet how much pointless [ __ ] you carry
in your wallet my father used to pull
out a catcher's mitt this big old
leather thing cards of people that would
never do business with him dollars just
errant breath mints all shoved into a
[ __ ] wallet everything God keys
receipts hotel room the you know the VIN
cards and things like that I'll tell you
what you need you need orig wallet
because it's a minimal front pocket wall
that's designed to streamline what you
carry every day it comes at titanium
carbon fiber aluminum dozen different
styles and colors it's so easy to
sanitize right you could take it because
it's so small you put it between your
hands look at it right now look at it
right now go get to go get the go get
the sanitizer we give them a
demonstration now you better remember
this I'm not doing this for free all the
goddamn time with the demonstrations go
get the sanitizer will show me to do it
this is for all of you that are confused
you don't know how to sanitize your
wallet you got to do it the right way
oh I am so sad we live in such a dirty
world there are viruses everywhere
trying to kill us they're all conspiring
to kill us
I will now sanitize my hand oh I have a
wallet it also needs to be sanitized
look at this
I've now sanitized my entire wallet and
my hands at the same time now I have a
sanitized wallet with no corona sorry
mr. Corona it looks like you're gonna
have to go somewhere else so that's why
you get the ridge right now there's a
million reasons to get the ridge you
don't need it's a cool little wallet but
you want to sanitize everything on you
right now I mean that's the game the
game is health right now that's the game
take the vitamin D strengthen your
immune system get the spoon I mean this
is the game drink a lot of water cut the
booze out unless you need to drink some
of it before you start buying the rest
of this [ __ ] and then get hammered and
get get the gourd out Regus thirty
thousand five star reviews and even if
they wrote 15 thousand of them or used
AI to write fifteen or twenty thousand
that's still ten thousand fuschia came
from actual people I'm kidding
everybody loves a rich we sell a lot of
rich wallets because they like it
there's a lifetime warranty it's a cool
wallet and I'll tell you right now man I
feel a lot better with orig wallet
because it can be easily sanitized and
that that's the future the future is is
is lean and clean
is it not lean and clean and clean lean
and clean is the future you know you
have a sanitized wallet right now yeah
it's nice no Crona what is what is that
what'd you get what'd you get for
yourself there would you get a what is
that which one is that this is the blue
cobalt one Wow Wow and I didn't go for
the clip I went for the band I like to
talk cash in the B yeah you tuck a
little cash right in that band like you
tuck your [ __ ] up between your legs
and then you have a [ __ ] get 10% off
today with free worldwide shipping your
returns but gonna Ridge calm / Tim
that's rich dark on /t I am and use code
T I am link in description of the all of
the links of all the sponsors let's
throw a magic spoon link in there as
well they're all gonna be in the YouTube
folks and we know it's a little late
this time hey hey go [ __ ] yourself but
buy the products because they help us
and we all were doing always for the
heroes always with it I don't go a day
when I don't see here I get my hair
doing all the time I I do all the food
food for the heroes I brought them food
to the hospital Whitney Cummings paid
for I do everything for the heroes all
of it I will take a photo with food I
did not pay for for the heroes that's
who I am
I will stand there and take a photo in
front of cedars-sinai with food that I
only really just I didn't even want
these people touching me these nurses I
was like one of them elbowed me like
stay away from me you're as good as dead
I'm kidding but here's the thing comedy
folks what are you gonna do
I'm gonna get out and perform again you
know when it when it's appropriate when
it's appropriate but you know all I do
is - for the heroes all right we're done
right with the ads okay rich calm
Tim tea I am doing stop comedy starting
this comedy starting to get back in
business a little bit clubs were opening
up very small percentage of the room 25%
I'm hearing mixed things some people say
it's fun
it doesn't look fun to me I've worked
pretty hard to perform four rooms full
of people if this is the new normal yes
I will eventually come out and do these
rooms I'm hoping it isn't the new normal
and I'm hoping that in time there will
be a return to some kind of normalcy and
that we'll be able to get some more
people in those rooms we could have
something that feels more like comedy
and
like just a crazy guy in a mall who's
held 75 people hostage
that is what my shows feel like anyway
like a guy who lost it in the mall with
a gun that's kind of what i market
myself as just a father of no children
but as a dad energy then he's lost it in
the mall some of my best shows were for
14 people in a room that seated 500 when
I was losing my mind in San Antonio with
the Improv screaming at the top my lunch
and those people just having a great
time because it was nobody could find
the club the mall was so poorly designed
I know shocker right and it was such a
poorly designed mall in the club's on
the fourth floor of the mall we know San
Antonio they don't like floor - so floor
four I mean come on I don't think so so
I just remember so I will get back out
there I'm gonna get back out there I
mean the times are the times are we're
now some magic spoon though right now
this we're not doing an ad read but
let's just have a little bit of it this
is the fruit flavor here you've still
got some milk good and the thing about
magic spoon folks is that it cures
Corona it is a cure secured prevents
preventative with you have Corona now or
will have Corona you'll never have it
now great thing about magic spoon cereal
is that it's what is this good it's
tasty never had it my life no I'm
kidding I enjoy it I like it because it
you don't feel guilty you know I don't
feel guilty after I eat anything I
should but I know but I'm now feeling
more guilty because I'm starting to
think about health because of Kovan
[ __ ] nor did I burn my mouth and I've
you ever burned your top of your mouth
and then cereals like a razor yeah
there's hearts so much it hurts so
[ __ ] much which is good somebody once
here meet you the rest of the podcast
but it's just there's nothing worse than
the roof of your mouth being burnt
being cut with the razor-sharp edge of
cereal and there's people that have done
that there's probably people that are
listening to the show that can identify
with that which is hot coffee
you know what's the restaurant you guys
don't want to go back to here's the
other thing let's get into this for a
minute because I people on Twitter too
like hey me and my boyfriend a big fans
of you I appreciate the hell out of that
can you can you set him a birthday
message no here's why I don't send my
family birthday messages okay so here's
a reality I don't get this is a 200th
episode of the show it's just balloons
and of it know enough move the [ __ ] on
okay we tried to get someone they
wouldn't come on I got to do their show
first it's a whole thing
so we will have them it'll be fun but
the reality of the situation is I love
all of my fans I appreciate you I miss
seeing you at meet and greets after the
after the podcast but like in a cameo
I'm not joining cameo
I'm not shading anyone who has joined it
is not for me I just can't for life me
be like hey hey Tom I know you're big
fan happy birthday but hey happy
birthday what are you and Marissa doing
for your big day I will blow my brains
out on cameo and I know that everyone
knows that Hey
hey Sheila hey Sheila your friend Rick
just wanted me to tell you
congrats on [ __ ] graduating nursing
school hero like nah I can't personally
do it I know that people do it I respect
people to do it people who talents I
don't have I to I cannot pretend to care
about your life okay I I will not do it
you will have to go somewhere else
there's a lot of people to do they're
much more popular than me it's not
happening it's not coming and I'm not
mad at you the you asked I'm not I
appreciate the listen but I will not
pretend to care about your life other
people pretend to care about your life
to the tune of two three four million
dollars a year I do not care I have
family members bodies ravaged with
cancer
barely the phone to them hello hi how
are you good yeah it's good huh I'm
better good I can't you know I was a
ghost you eat no doll yeah eat now
I'm kidding up now I'm not but the boy
is what are you gonna do let me go hey
hey hey hey Kelly
I heard Kelly a real fan you look to
show go you know well well [ __ ]
franca some pretty cool some plan for
you Kelly
turn around Frank standing there with a
knife you cheatin [ __ ] he's gonna get
you stop crying you know what you did I
would do at a meal for murderers where I
would announce your murder that's right
you had announced you more I did
announce tragedies breakups you know but
I just can't bring myself to treat you
like children and pretend that I give a
flying [ __ ] it's your breath I don't
care it's that it's my birthday in
January it doesn't matter I didn't get
him a present for his wedding here's a
reality I'm and you know why that is
because if coronavirus can't be
delivered don't make a face I wanted to
do it but I refuse to put him and his
fiance at risk to make me feel good
enough would you know me you've heard
hours of me on the show you can't
imagine that there's a part of me that
wants to wish you and your boyfriend a
happy birthday how about this
this is for everyone happy birthday for
all of you in the past and in the future
that's the happy birthday enjoy it
what here's the thing with the Cameo by
the way I think it's funny when like
somebody did it with blue Govich
somebody had the boy a [ __ ] to it for
to promote my Caroline show things like
that are clearly funny people do with
Chris Hanson it's very funny but like
who are the people on ironically using
cameo who are the people that genuinely
want [ __ ] the chick who played
[ __ ] you know the chick who played uh
you know I don't know
Delta Burke's friend on Designing Women
like who wants Kathy Najimy wishing them
happy birthday the fat chick from the my
blanket Kathy Najimy who's hilarious but
like she's the [ __ ] that she's in
hocus pocus to fat witch from hocus
pocus
it's young cameos you might not be she
better be on cameo of course she is
who's who's go and I genuinely want the
fat witch from hocus but [ __ ] don't you
have money a hundred and fifty dollars I
mean she's great she's guy love her in
that movie I love her in a million
things but I mean enough already
I get it I'll be on it [ __ ] next week
probably I just can't I just can't you
know who are the people is it just is it
rich people that just Hollywood has
fallen so far that it's fun to watch
your favorite celebrities who are
scrounging around on their floor for cat
food is it fun to watch them have to be
degraded to wish you a happy but they
don't care about you they don't want to
be near you how nice was 90's Fame when
if somebody went near Sharon Stone they
got a gun in their mouth if some if
Sharon Stone is having lunch the IV and
you went near you were physically
removed now this [ __ ] has got to wish
you happy Valentine's Day what a [ __ ]
hellscape I know that there's a lot of
people on this sort of good people I
just you know there's a lot of people on
this city suffering you know a lot of
people are suffering Abby Lee Miller
that [ __ ] from Dance Moms
how much the Cameo from that fat [ __ ] Oh
mark recently active of course this
[ __ ] lose resin oh my go over make
cookie one of the right 99
I mean this fat well Audrey cried for 30
minutes she's showing everyone she said
it was the best present ever thank you
so much this is the woman who did Dance
Moms which I thought was a great show
because I like to see greatness demanded
of children I like to see children cry
and realize your mistakes many of those
many of those kids kill themselves some
of them don't they grow up to be great
people listen to this talk about
stunning estates yeah I was in a friend
buddy's house today where I got
sunburned and his mom rents a house in
Malibu everywhere every summer for the
month of July I was like you know I'd
like to rent something down there I have
no I can't of course can't afford it but
I just like to enter into conversations
like that so potentially calls my bluff
she puts me on the phone with her
realtor like a real estate agent so I'm
like okay so what's great about these la
real estate agents is to like right out
of a Robert Altman movie like they're
just exactly what you'd imagine them to
be like yours dialogue written for them
and handed to them first of all they're
always super familiar with you they're
like they're like a a waiter at Friday's
it's a little weird who's like who gets
down on his knees when you're a little
kid you're they were your dad he's like
hey champ hey buddy I bet you're pretty
hungry I bet you want some [ __ ] [ __ ]
of fingers don't it's like you know so I
I get on a phone this well of course her
name is Tracy every Realtors name is
Tracy okay
Tracy's either the name of a porn star
or a realtor okay and the real estate is
it porn is much more reputable so I get
on the phone with this woman and she's
like hey Tim how are you and I'm like
good and she's like let me tell you
something right now this market in
Malibu it's a real knife fight it's a
real knife fight down here in Malibu I
don't care what the government's saying
people are snatching up properties left
and right so I'm just letting you know
what it is and I'm like okay Ike I don't
want to get into a knife fight in Malibu
I can't I will get into maybe a shoving
match in Silver Lake you know maybe a
fender bender in Studio City but I don't
think a knife fight in Malibu is
appropriate uh and she's like so is your
budget under 40 a month
she means forty thousand I'm like yeah
yeah around there I mean I'm like
because if I'm gonna spend more than
knowledge
in a house right she's like right
because I'll send you some options
because this could be your Summer of
Love
she's a whole different world out here
Tim it's a whole different worlds that
cracked out of her face she coked out
her husband's [ __ ] her assistant
she's like Tim it's a real knife fight
here in Malibu
I haven't felt since I found out my
husband [ __ ] my sister last Christmas
it's a real knife fight here in Malibu
the only thing I ate last week was
adderall and grapefruit juice it's a
real knife fight come armed or not it's
a knife fight here in Malibu my son
thinks he's a woman it's a knife fight
take the blades out and get cut
someone's getting caught my name is
Tracy and I'm a real estate agent and
you can't take that away from me you
could take everything my fat sister and
her husband in Ohio those three
disgusting kids she's beat cancer three
[ __ ] times they're so happy and their
above-ground pool with their poverty but
she doesn't understand I get in that
white Jaguar license plate says sold and
I drive down the PCH and I say it's a
nice sign it's a goddamn nice sign are
you ready but not really I'm not really
I don't Tracy Tracy you seem a bit
intense I feel like I'm I'm not really
ready for this what we sword fight I
don't I'm not ready for him it's that
intensity what she hangs on to her
husband blew her brains out years ago
she found his brain matter all over the
kitchen table
she didn't even move it she just sat
there took a little sip of cold brew and
stared right out in the beautiful ocean
she's got a stunning estate the stunning
view the knife fighter life's a knife
fight that's probably high school
yearbook quote life said life's a knife
fight I can't believe my my goddamn I
can't believe I got so sunburned I'm
really [ __ ] up like my sunburn it's
like bad looks bad right yeah it's like
a bad one it's very very bad my nose is
like running I think that's this room
it's your nose running oil - it's the
[ __ ] studio I'm like minute 30 it
starts running yeah
it's the studio thank God I had this
magic spoon [ __ ] hurts my mouth but it
won't hurt yours what do you think of it
isn't it a nice cereal I legitimately
really like it
the fruity flavor is the best flavor
it's good I mean it's listen good it's
good it's it's low you know low and low
and what it has to be in high and that
wood it has to be as well you know it's
both low and the bad and high and the
good and that's all we ask
and you don't feel shitty after you eat
it breakfast is a knife fight you know
what I mean it's real knife fight this
market for healthy cereal give me a
cauchy you [ __ ] TiVo wearing Dyke put
the Kashi down it sucks it's not good so
I don't think I'll be renting anything
in Malibu so I'm just not prepared for
that level of aggression what options
that should give you anything I mean I
have to email her and I probably have to
tell her I've been I tell her I've no
credit right I'm at case or anyone in
Mal but who wants to rent me something
with no credit I have money but no
credit how do they feel about hey how do
you feel about this let me talk let's
talk about our knife before we get into
the knife fight because our nice kind of
doll I found it on a train and it's got
it has some dried blood on it so it has
worked before but I just don't know if
we can get you know they probably have a
real nice sharp shiny knife you know
from one of those Japanese blocks would
you know one of those knife collections
that people buy is almost like a samurai
sword and I'm coming in with like a dull
butter knife used to kill a mother
it's a goddamn knife fight I just love
the way they talk man I love I love real
estate agents I there's nobody I like
more then if there is deep as a puddle
there as deep as a puddle these pit I
mean there is nothing underneath there
it doesn't go deeper than that sir its
market hey Tim this markets a real knife
fight so I'll tell you this right now I
don't care what the government's saying
people are snatching up these properties
left and right it's a real knife fight
down here Malba you know how many times
a day she says that hey Karen how are
you Tracy just getting back to him it's
heating up down here mark it's a real
knife fight you know how it is they make
stew
bydd jokes it have to be like you can't
offend anyone so the jokes have to be
like dad jokes you know they have to be
like well you know what happens you get
a little tequila I could be a little
wild
ha ha I wish I felt you know that's what
there aren't drugs to I mean they're on
there have to be pumping themselves out
because you know here's the other thing
they're not wrong it's not not a knife
fight like it's a lot of rich people
that have just throwing houses at each
other down there and everybody wants to
be in the best place for the summer well
I mean it's just funny when you hear one
of them talk because they're it's
exactly what I would have imagined her
to say it's like perfect perfect have
you ever met someone and they were human
being and it's so disappointing and
you're like no no don't tell me don't
tell me your son has MS tell me it's a
knife fight no I want to hear about the
knife fight I wanna hear about the
billionaire's throwing houses at each
other on the beach oh there's only a
certain amount of plots and everyone
wants to build no oh no you have a lump
on your breast no what about the knife
thigh
can we go back to the good old knife
fight the fake knife fight that everyone
fights with wire transfers and lawyers
would you like mouthed with I was
driving around then there's some
beautiful beautiful homes and you know
God love the people that are there she's
nice the salt water air is nice the fish
is not that good
you know I don't understand people
Malibu Sifu and real and I mean the East
Coast fish is just better the cuts of
meat they're colder they're insulated
more they're fatty or the fish they
taste better it's very fishy out here
the Pacific fish is very fishy I don't
know why that is but the East Coast fish
is just better and I'm a big seafood
person and I gotta be honest it's a
little disappointing that's why you
gotta just put it in a taco here you
just gotta put just put it in the taco
just put it in the taco a little avocado
crema come on put a little pico de gallo
and
that's it's very hard to just get a
grilled piece of fish here and after you
go wow there's none of that just put it
in the top put it on tortilla and just
be done with it be done with it it's
[ __ ] fishy I don't know why there's
not much we could do with the 200th
episode folks you know I mean a lot of
people that we we could have I don't
want to do the zoom I don't have people
on zoom I don't like that I know other
people like it listen there's a million
shows doing that if you want that go and
get that go and get that go and defend
Bill Gates on zoom do whatever you want
to do and I'm not even going to bill I
mean I did for 30 minutes but it's his
wacky boy
she's just gotta be he's oh he's a wild
man and he gotta rein him in a little
bit Billy Bale Billy Boy what are you
trying to do trying to get rid of the
Sun bill raining in reining in bill
music I want to save the planet for
climate change and it's like and what
have the people ruining another way step
aside and let the lava get him what
happened to those billionaires because
they step aside let the lava get him
yeah yeah we [ __ ] to plan it up let
the planet eat us don't deny the planet
that joy don't deny the planet the joy
of eating us striking back and lashing
out at us please don't deprive the but
what about the planet have you ever
thought about what the planet wants
global warming's nothing to do with the
planet it's a whole Carla bit it's
everything to do with us planet doesn't
give a [ __ ] so it's like Oh bill wants
to save the planet it's like no he wants
to save your kids dance studio he wants
to save the strip mall and fine I get it
I'm not against humanity but like let's
get [ __ ] real here he's the best
person ever bill
don't say anything he said morph of
anyone that's ever lived that's the
thing going around Facebook there going
he said more for people than any person
that's ever lived and people are saying
mean things about Bill it's crazy just
cuz he wants to shoot nuclear weapons at
the moon see what happens he wants to
send a spaceship full of nukes and
detonate it and blow them
for a 4th of July show cuz it's better
than fireworks and everyone's mad at him
now why he just wants a little chip and
all of you children and whenever they
have a negative thought it blinks and
they're told to never have a negative
thought ever again and to get up every
day to talk about how much they love
this country and sing the national net
what's wrong with that I don't
understand why anyone would be bit mad
at Billy Boy manscaped I've asked for a
free man skate for the last [ __ ] six
months and haven't gotten one so thanks
a lot everybody
man skate please send me a free thing
flowers are blooming the grass is
growing and it's time for you to clear
out your underbrush with manscape you
could trim your hedges safely this is
like real start real estate jokes do
yourself a favor and get the right tools
for the job because it's a goddamn knife
fight down there below the belt you know
what it is it's a goddamn knife fight
you got a big Bush manscaped is the only
Brent dedicated to below the belt coping
I will say this manscape is good it's
the best pube trimmer on the market it's
what it is
have skin-safe technology it won't Nick
or snag your sack it's the perfect bad
guy but a crop preserver ant they
chasing ball deodorant moisturizer it's
getting hot outside this will keep your
balls from sticking the crop Reviver
which will keep your ball smelling fresh
just like the spring flowers I think you
should just leave your blade your ball
smell the way they smell pheromones
report just let you know let it let it
hang out let's not get too crazy your
ball smelling like jasmine anyway the
point is there its call to action I'm
not supposed to say that
verbatim not supposed to say that get
20% off free shipping when you use the
code team at manscape comm if you're a
man or a woman with a dick or want a
dick or practicing having a dick or
investing in a day Acorah I'm gonna have
a dick on layaway manscape calm manscape
calm from what could Tim for 20% off
your first order get the big get the
thing that you need the lawnmower 3.0
it's the best pube trimmer on the market
it's waterproof cordless and designed to
protect your most sensitive area so
if you're in the bath or the table oh
you're right in the pool in front of the
family and you want to do it in front of
everybody
invite a bunch of people to your house
and you shave your [ __ ] in your own pool
and if they don't like you tell them
it's safe because the man escapes is
waterproof whatever you want to do but
it's literally even if you need this you
need it the norelco body grooms not that
good it's their only competition it's
just quite frankly not that good so with
the perfect package you also get it okay
you get you get but buy it buy it if you
need it buy it and use the code Tim do
you like to show or not if you want me
to be in Malibu or not you want me to
live with you [ __ ] animals and in a
guy I don't even know what you people
are some FEMA tent you're getting this a
shortwave radio you're sitting there -
you practicing some [ __ ] Civil War
militia I don't know what the hell
you're doing you want me to live like
you people want me to be on cameo like
an animal wish your people happy
birthday
it's that happy graduation Sara
[ __ ] that buy the trimmer shave your
junk use the promo code Tim I mean how
much would debate I'm selling ball hair
trimmers on a [ __ ] podcast how much
worse do you want it to get from me I'm
a remarkably talented individual my
talent far exceeds most of what's on
there but am I on SNL no I'm selling
dick pills and bald hair trimmers and
cereal on a podcast how much how long
you want this to happen
can't you get McKay yeah can you notch
me up a little bit here and get the
trimmer please other people get big
deals they sit around their agent calls
go who lose gonna stuff money in your
abs so you can go lose it cuz you've
never had a thought in your life your
entire career is a [ __ ] joke it's a
practical joke that people started to
take seriously and now you own a house
I'm selling ball hair trimmers for the
love of Christ please get the trimmer
that is all I'm asking
give it to a friend it's a nice fun
podcast camp it's a fun gift for men to
give each other nothing gay about it but
if you want to suck off your friend this
is also a fun way to let them know this
is what it needs to be please
please people here would script deals
movie deals
I'm calling Realtors I'm bored
the Tim dillagi was brought to you by
expressive VP and tell us about the
drones it was very interesting been
Virtual Private Networks are huge now
the government's trying to [ __ ] with
everybody if you're doing anything with
sensitive information you don't want
people you know whether it's banking or
whatever it is you don't want people
finding out where you are you don't want
to be marketed and hounded and annoyed
everybody's doing VPN this is a big
thing and tell us about the drones Ben
because there was something about
Charles you told me all around the porch
my friend told me that if you want to
fly drones you have to log your your
flights a flight log so they know the
government knows exactly where you're
going because there's certain places you
can't go right so if you have a VPN or
something like that you can say you're
somewhere else and then you know fly
around the Hollywood sign fly down the
Hollywood you're not allowed to fly down
the Hollywood sign if you don't have a
VPN I don't know probably not I mean
most areas are probably restricted in
the city right I guess yeah yeah so
expressvpn is great for protecting your
privacy and security online so you can
also use to unlock foreign movies and TV
shows that are only available in other
countries pinch Doctor Who on Netflix in
the United Kingdom watch spirited away
on Netflix in Japan and so much more
they sent me that CEO a couple of
people's of the CEO like he only got a
year and yet all this horrible child
porn this guy was the CEO he rents a
Bitcoin company I forget where it was he
was horrible child porn CEO yeah he just
happened it was crazy the guy and
nothing in and out it's no no just just
just just search just search pedophile
arrested or something he was sentenced
he did a year he only did a year just
hit news hit news yeah Utah CEO gets 210
days in jail for having 13 thousand
files of infant and child rape and be
she algae god is horrific this is not
what they want me to say in the head
yeah that's only god it's [ __ ] crazy
I just thought it was funny in the court
he's like I know I was binging Doctor
Who
no no no no I I was using the VPN to
binge
Doctor Who or watch spirited away on
Japanese Netflix this is a big
misunderstanding here I've I've had a
big misunderstanding ah wait a minute
I'm here because I use Japanese Netflix
right like no it's all about the child
poor and you're like wait a minute
this is cuz I broke into UK Netflix
expressvpn works for any streaming
service Netflix Amazon Hulu BBC you need
a VPN folks you need it you don't want
Nancy Pelosi following you around
nagging you it works on all your devices
any phone tablet we use it we use
expressvpn it's great we you know we
correspond with some people Whitney Webb
and people like that who don't want to
be tracked because they they're you know
deep in it's fast it's no buffering and
there's no lag streaming HD without any
issue on any device in any part of your
house if you visit my special link right
now expressvpn comm / Tim Dylan TI m TI
ll o n expressvpn comm / Tim Dylan you
can get an extra three months of
expressvpn for free support the show
watch what you want protect yourself it
expressvpn calm / Tim Dylan that's the
show folks episode 200 the bed we are
moving on one episode free every week if
you want to get another episode
patrons $5 a month if you have even more
money give us twenty a month you get one
extra episode a week plus a monthly you
know two hour-long episode as well so
that's the deal if you don't have the
money because things are [ __ ] right
now everything we do here it will always
be free you'll get four episodes every
week every month for free you'll get all
of our videos and should like that 100%
of the time for free so don't worry
there's more than enough [ __ ] out there
if you have the money and you want
actual stuff it's a great way to support
the show and we appreciate it but this
has been 200 episodes 200 hours of
talking really more really more because
we've done multi hour episodes
probably close to 250 hours of of
talking it's a lot of talking we started
this in 2016 with a great rate comp
the bass of loose Gomez I done Legion of
skanks I was doing some other pockets
I'd done a bunch of pockets before I did
one called the unbelievable podcast was
about aliens I did the early Tim Dylan
show the guys from Queens Network in
2011 with Andrews Aryan and then
eventually I started doing this show a
tre comp out of the gasps digital studio
which was in Ralph Sutton's apartment of
course with leaves you skanks Louis
loved those guys and then meet him and
Nick still do a thing on YouTube
bastard radio Lewis name that we don't
have to tell you that you knew then you
knew that when you heard the name I got
to start doing that batter I mean I just
queue it on zoom' and my mom I like it
people don't really complain about the
sound quality though people have been so
beaten down with everything they don't
care probably better for how couple the
mic but who cares but that's a fun show
but yeah and then we've been doing the
Tim Dylan show we left cast I moved to
LA and we just wanted to go independent
it was time and when did we do that you
moved to LA June 1st I think you were
independent in like July or August yes
sir the patron September yeah so the
show's been [ __ ] the show's grown
massively we have us a few celebrity
listeners isn't that nice
and the celebrities are Bill Gates
Melinda Gates his team of killers he's
gonna hire to descend on my apartment
and kill me yeah I mean it's been a wild
ride when I started podcasting I didn't
think it was going to be my career I
thought it's gonna be something that I
would do while I got my show on Comedy
Central how funny is that
I thought podcast who's gonna be just a
fun thing I could do to stay strong as a
stand-up while I got my show on Comedy
Central Network that now doesn't exist
essentially as of a few weeks ago it
really doesn't exist um
so especially thank God I pivoted the
only reason I've been successful at
anything people ask me like are you all
are you hard at work or you this and the
other thing sure there's some innate
talent or whatever but the reality is I
get bored easily so I got bored with
stand-up and I still love Stan I still
do it but I got bored with it so I
started doing podcasting and then I got
bored with podcasting for me and Ben
started making
content videos things like that to put
on YouTube social media so the reality
is if you know anything's I think it's
about getting bored and doing new things
not stopping doing old things but adding
new things here repertoire and we really
we really started doing the show in the
show became stronger because a ban has
essentially been and me have really made
it into something that we both enjoy we
both enjoy doing and we enjoy making
these videos we want we want this to
grow and get as big as you guys will
allow to get um but yeah I mean from
where we are now even we were a year ago
or a few years ago it's like you can't
even it's not it's not identifiable and
Joe Rogan's a huge part of that by
having me on the show as much as he's
had me on the show and by promoting us
and putting out our videos and
everything like that and you know that
of course we don't forget that and
there's a lot of other people that have
helped me out here too but I mean I'm
not gonna mention them by name because
it's like whatever you know it's you
know it wasn't the hugest help it was
fine I mean Joe's a bigger help you know
be honest not gonna go down a laundry
list of you know people that we get it
okay you know these other shows I've
helped out by being on let's be honest
so the reality is the reality is that
we're grateful we're grateful for the
heroes yeah anyone who's had me on your
podcast a hero in my book you're a hero
but it's been a wild ride we are
broadcasting at the end of the world
this is uh this is the apocalypse I know
most people it's not to selling shoes
you know the stinkers you know the great
thing about this country and about
civilizations like the longer and longer
things like this go the shutdown the
worsening economy the black Mura
whatever you want to call it that that I
heard the black Mira was named that
because it was like what a computer
looks like when it's off yeah yeah that
just looms larger and larger that just
grows that just grows now as outside
gets more dangerous or more contentious
you know as it looks it's gonna start
looking worse you know cities are gonna
go bankrupt in states and they're not
gonna
to keep anything up and the people are
gonna get angrier and they're gonna is
gonna be civil unrest gonna be all that
stuff most likely and as the outside
gets uglier you're gonna fall into the
computer you're gonna fall into that
black mirror just gonna fall in there
and then you're going to exist primarily
digitally for the rest of your life's I
mean this is just what is going to
happen some of you may hold out the last
vestiges of freedom that you you you
know drink deep the wine of freedom it's
there's not a ton left in your glass I
don't even mean somewhere well in
government I just mean like everything
is integrated itself into this you know
you [ __ ] I mean every which way you're
just gonna the future is digital it's on
a screen your friends are on screens
it's it's horrific it's a heart I hate
that it sucks and it's not real and a
lot of the people that have gotten
massive digitally when you look at them
and they're it's not like guys a Krogan
who remember the other side they
remember real life you know but it needs
to stand up so he's always out there
with you but when you talk about these
big YouTube guys a lot of these guys
that we meet out here that are big
YouTube guys and not so much aglow ghen
Paul because those guys still are out in
the real world he's fighting he's doing
like real things but there are these
guys who like never they just exist
online and when you meet them there's
something missing and I can't identify
what it is they're just they're kind of
not there they're only alive if they're
on a screen there's something sick about
it there's something sad about it and
that thing will be the future it's
unfortunate but that's probably I mean
not to deliver it to stop you know I
mean the show the show for last three
years I think it's been largely positive
and so I don't want to do a negative
thing on the 200th episode it's not me
it's not me and it's not what you expect
you know start your business it's gonna
be great
so hustle and grind hustle grind hustle
grind how's the ground attack ready
uh-huh
how's it grass but I will say this man I
mean we would always joke around about
this situation that we now find
ourselves in broadcasting from a room as
the entire world falls apart this seems
to be one of the only appropriate art
forms at the moment
it does seem like that it doesn't seem
like it's I don't know that I need to be
it's some you know comedy club while
people are scarfing down chicken fingers
this this seems much more pertinent and
this seems fitting it really seems like
it fits the time that we're in I I love
live performance I hope it comes back it
will come back and I'll be out there
doing it when it does come back but
there's just something about this that
just for the moment for the for the
moment and maybe for the foreseeable
future feels right and I'm very happy
that we did this and we we start and by
did this I mean the coronavirus we
started the coronavirus we engineered
this and released it and it's it's
worked so well I had no idea no I mean
the podcast it's a it's a crazy time but
I you know I don't want everybody that
just [ __ ] exists on the internet but
that seems like where we're headed it
seems like we're we're headed some of
you have been there for years so
everybody world just catching up to you
now you know you've been on a Chan 4chan
8 khun kon john martin whatever it is
making all your friends there and having
fun conversations about the future and
we're all catching up eventually it'll
all be it'll all be on the you know so
online now right so I mean this is happy
I'm happy about this I mean you know not
not a I don't know I'm not thrilled
about it but we're adjusting to it and
I'm hoping we can adjust that I'll never
be the guy that just wants to exist in
this medium I'll never be the guy that
just wants to do it I'll always be i'll
always enjoy as much as I enjoy the show
as much I do this I'll always love a
shitty comedy club in the middle of
nowhere looking at real people seeing
their faces shaking their hands when we
were allowed to do that that I'll always
enjoy that more even though I'm good at
this and this is fun I was enjoyed that
more because each
that's actually I don't know who you are
out there I know I don't know that I
want to know
but that exchange that we have of energy
in a real-life situation a comedy club
or in a theater that to me was always
that's what it's about to me this is in
support of that this is all in support
of that and we hope we get back there
sooner rather than later but this is a
great [ __ ] show I mean if I could
list every horrible podcast out there I
mean if I could go through them
I mean God but I can't because these
people my colleagues it's you know if
you ever been to an office you walk in
every day hey Linda you suck you can't
you go hey Linda good to see ya
it's what it is I'm kidding everyone's
great at what they do and I'm an honor
I'm honored to be in a community of
comedians in America that every one of
them's a joy and a blessing
Netflix's has two newspaper movie on
Netflix man is good they're wrong Missy
it's good and Lauren lapkus who said to
me when I was doing your show she said
to me once I was doing I was doing jokes
on the show and I was being funny that's
kind of what the show was you do jokes
on and Lauren lapkus look at me she's
like what are you the hot take I so I
you know me and her we're not like
besties we don't really know each other
but let me tell you this she makes that
film she's [ __ ] amazing she's so good
in that movie and it's so she's it's so
[ __ ] funny because of her and other
people Schwartz's and a lot of great
people are in it's Paige Steiner it's a
great movie but lapkus is just to stand
out like crushes the movie and yes I am
the hot take guy and one of my hot takes
is how lovely you are in the film
how could you are in the movie so that's
it folks I mean that's the State of the
Union that's where we are and where
we're going there's nothing you or Bill
Gates can say about that so if you want
to sell me some you want to sue me Billy
Boy you Melinda get to it
but I bet you ignore this best you
ignore me and you keep finding ways to
block out the Sun